why do I like feet oh yeah I need this
answer Big Time foot fetish guys big
time
I don't [ __ ] them
okay don't make it yeah so they're
they're two reasons okay Left Foot Right
Foot yeah that's all you need to know
um there are two reasons
um
okay so there's true fetish okay and in
the clinical sense a fetish is something
that somebody actually requires in order
to get aroused okay so so you know so
fetish can be like people talk about
fetish light or people talk about but
then they're they're true fetishes where
people actually require
um feet or okay let's think about the
the extreme fetishes right and uh um so
this is the dark side of this okay so
let's think like let's put feet there
but it doesn't have to be dark but then
you could think like
um feces
dead bodies right bestiality this is
dark stuff exactly it's an immediate so
we have a circuit we have circuits in
our brain that immediately give us the
reaction you just give you put your head
back it's kind of like Get me away from
that topic
yeah
right so our brain tends to put us into
approach types that which we call a
petitive
like smell in the odor taste you want to
get close to something or aversive right
animals have this humans have this okay
but if you think about the classic
fetishes all of those feet historically
had the potential to be sites of
infection right historically not now
right we wash our feet we have socks we
have shoes dead bodies obviously very
infectious what do we do with dead
bodies we we preserve them when we get
them into the ground or we cremate them
depending on your your leanings whatever
um but you try and not get infected by
them this is all has been known a long
time
things like feces are contagious right
we know this that it's putrid or vomit
these things
this is the harsh way to start off the
discussion
think about it all of these tend to
evoke for most people and aversive
response you want to get away from it so
there are people who have this
appetitive approach to things that are
very infectious and a lot a lot of the
fetishes at their extreme reflect a kind
of I don't want to say miswiring but a a
flip in what normally happens right when
you see vomit you don't go I'm gonna
take a sniff for that but when you smell
big fresh baked cookies you're like I'm
gonna take a smell that's how I feel
about it exactly okay okay so these are
like cookies so that so the thing here
is people don't develop fetishes to like
water bottles or to tables or to like
posts to things that so there's this
kind of edginess of it's like they're
sort of dancing between aversive and
repetitive and that's what makes it edgy
leather is another fetish right and you
know this it has to do with like animal
hides people think now a lot of this is
speculation because we don't really know
how all this evolved but because that's
extreme fetishes but then there are
people who have have like they like a
nice clean beautiful foot yeah
exactly right
in yeah
you know like the or the Contour or you
think about um like for some people
um they they like they like Toes or they
like
um or they will like leather is like a
turn on to them right but a lot of a lot
of what we think of as a petitive kind
of sexual arousal type things are right
at that edge like you know everybody
knows or should know right yeah I think
it's well known that like a little bit
of leg like a little hint like what's
the slit up the side of the skirt it's a
hint right it's not it's very different
than a than you know less clothing
overall it's a hint at what's there and
the way the nervous system works is
through contrast you know you only see
light objects through dark objects and
so on so this like playing
if you look historically at clothing you
can think of like Victorian era clothing
or like the high collar everything
covered just the face the Pasty face or
you think about like if you watch that
show madman or when there are these
lines in there where they're like shorts
are getting skirted skirts are getting
shorter excuse me
um that's my Lex dixia coming back the
um what you can imagine that during the
60s in particular in the 70s like
clothing was moving from less and less
of a hint and more and more of a reveal
nowadays we are living in a time where
there is a lot of reveal right I mean
it's pretty incredible right how much if
clothing has evolved but so I do want to
just frame up that there there's like
classic fetish that can actually be a
clinical issue because people can't get
aroused without exposing themselves to
dangerous infection right that's sort of
the extreme but then there's this kind
of subtle playing of of hints and
hinting and suggestions like
counter-intuitive to like Darwinism and
evolution and all that no one really
knows I mean like that
I wasn't consulted in the design phase
for any of this you know you know so
like I don't know but but there there
does seem to be uh well the human mating
dance right is a very complicated thing
right yeah it's a it's a it's a
complicated dance between
um it's all about obviously it's about
two things really it's about possibility
and it's about negotiating power right
and there's been a lot of beautiful
writings about this that you know when
you like think about objectifying
somebody or that let's say them
objectifying you right when objectifying
someone is you want them right you
desire them but you don't need them for
anything you don't need them to pay your
rent you don't need them for emotional
support you don't need to be held you
don't need any of that The Closer you
get get to somebody you form a real
emotional bond the harder it is to
objectify them they're no longer just an
object you're no longer just an object
to them so that the human mating dance
is one of at first objectification yeah
anyone who argues different has uh is
probably not of our species and then
slowly over time less and less
objectification and more emotional
dependence but don't you think that you
still need to objectify a little so
absolutely in all of the literature like
the person who's most commonly um I like
being certified yeah and I think some
people do and some people don't I think
that a lot of there's a great book it's
got a terrible title uh in my opinion um
but the the book is called can love last
it's written by a very serious
psychologist that talks about this that
sexual attraction is is uh the thing of
objectification but then as you enter
into relationship you lose that and so a
lot of times people have affairs people
will start looking at pornography
excessively instead of their person so a
lot of the um they give a really
incredible example of how relationships
can continue a long periods of time with
a lot of excitement like sexual
excitement but also healthy attachment
Yeah by cycling in and out of
objectification yeah attachment
objectification attachment You Know It's
Tricky right because everyone loves the
when you get to the point of
relationship where you just just hang
out you just watch movies and stuff but
then you know if you if you're not
actually objectifying each other every
once in a while you need to it can go
really flat 100 and then we always hear
like oh you know after 20 years they're
no longer together or you see celebrity
couples where one or both are like super
attractive and you're like he cheated on
her yeah well how could that possibly be
it's because the world objectified her
but at some point they hit the kind of
best friends mode you know and I think
how do you stop that well there's okay
so there's a chemical version all this
that has to do with kids and this
they're really cool data on this in
humans there's a hormone called
prolactin it's involved in milk let down
for
um nursing you know when mothers nurse
you know there but it's also released in
men and women when they have kids and it
literally suppresses sexual desire and
emphasizes laying down a body fat making
you more still it's all there to direct
your energy towards racism
physiological thing I did that before I
had kids it happens before yeah it's a
nesting what people you see this in
Birds you see this in humans what people
think is that it's laying down of fat
stores in order to anticipate the long
nights of No Sleep
listen our species is fundamentally
about making more of ourselves yeah and
protecting our young and and food
but I use them interchangeably okay
so it's interesting also okay to get to
thoroughly answer your foot question
yeah if I were to look at the
representation of your body surface in
your brain what that means is in your
brain you have a map of your body's
surface
there are certain areas on your body
that you have very little sensitivity
it's we measure this by 2.2 Point
discrimination it's called so what I do
is I take two two fingers and I poke
them against the middle of your back
with you looking in the other direction
behind your book like this I say how how
many places am I touching you'd say two
but if I move them this far apart you'd
say one why because you don't it's like
you don't have many pixels back there
but if I do that on your hand right you
have very high two-point discrimination
two pins right next to each other you
say those are two points what does this
mean in your brain you have a lot more
representation of certain areas of your
body which areas of your body fingertips
lips face feet and genitals and the
representation of the feet and the
genitals in males and females is right
next to each other in the brain this
some people there's a guy at UC San
Diego whose last name is ramachandran
his first name is even harder to
pronounce so I'm not even gonna try and
what he showed or wait was that people
who have
uh a foot amputated they have a phantom
foot they sort of think it's still there
and when they experience orgasm
oftentimes they will experience it in
their Phantom foot so a lot of people
you know part of the orgasm responds is
a curling back of the toes and a bunch
of other things back yeah curling back
of the toes what about forward oh that
means something's really is that what
happens no I'm just kidding
yeah
before you go right now if you're
getting crazy heads I I honestly haven't
I might have this backwards but um uh if
I do I apologize I don't think I've ever
been like like that like huh
maybe maybe you're backwards when you're
coming which way are you facing yeah I
think I'm facing well are you on all
four I think it's curl the toes
of your um uh northerner yeah if you're
in Australia
it's like the toilet bowl like twirling
the other way
do you spread your toes when you orgasm
let me think about coming yeah yeah
sometimes I go out sometimes sometimes
yeah I think it varies wow I don't know
how good the head is yeah
what's interesting is early on in my
career I studied sex differentiation and
sexual behavior and you know it's
fundamental right we're all here because
some sperm
I did
I mean it was the same universe it's
almost like an alumni box oh for real
what was the most popular Street Del
Playa and sure for uh DP you know what
I'm saying hey yeah I didn't live on DP
you did it no but he was there in the
year I partied there I was there in the
era where people pushed houses off of
cliffs on deep yeah it was crazy yeah I
mean and then a bunch of Darkness
happened later after I left yeah I did
mass shootings and stuff but after I
left them too oh that was after you left
yeah yeah that town is an interesting
mix of um it's one square mile that's
located directly next to the school and
all the kids live there and nobody but
kids lives there and it's an absolute
debauchery it is I mean it was crazy one
of the we had a storm that clogged all
the storm drains and people just bought
rafts and were literally like going down
and just the amount of alcohol consumed
there is insane they're no adults
they're just no adults it's a it's a
wild wild place
um so your feet are very sensitive yeah
your genitals are very sensitive your
lips are very sensitive and so these
so-called erogenous zones are really
just High sensitivity zones so I'm what
I'm I'm normal
as long as you don't need anything weird
that they don't like I think y'all are
the weird ones well what do we do with
people that like feed them why should we
lobotomize them let them answer the um
so well there's this idea of an arousal
template right like people have
an array of things that to them are
arousing and for some people that
arousal template is very narrow and very
specific yeah and that can be
problematic right that means they have
to find somebody or situations where
that you know that works and only that
works yeah
um and there are safe ways that people
do that right now they're like um I'm
not on the apps because that's not my
thing but I I researched this a lot um
through other people
um like there are now apps like that app
the newest one is this app field right
field is very much where people can be
extremely specific about what they want
in fact there are people now going on
the internet
they were only interested in sexting for
instance people who are like I wonder
people who want a relationship friendly
to sex sex like fire or only with my
wife last week and she called me she's
like did you mean to send me that what's
this
no I was like trying to be like cute and
stuff and she was like what the what the
[ __ ] is going on like I think she
thought I was cheating or something like
that she's like why would you say that
do you signal when you send those I
don't signal but there's something like
when are you gonna Peg me again
he's a professional
another DM you guys yeah I learned from
a friend who uh was in the Securities
Community for a long time that any
thought that isn't in your head is
available for download and so that's uh
that's scary
um oh it's out there it's out there it's
out there yeah okay so so basically
there are fetishes of the strict like
definition of fetish you think
infectious stuff and and that can be
problematic and then there are people
have an arousal template a bunch of
things that they like yeah right just
being there you know it's like how
narrow is your template yeah and I think
that
um most people would probably agree that
having some range some diversity of that
template like look some people like
um sweet soft sex some people like
rougher sex some people like an array of
that yeah some people are you know uh
and this is discussed in certain
communities more than others but some
people are like pure dominant pure
submissive some people are what they
call switch right there's this um
there's this whole landscape yeah and
that's because a lot of the like what
people don't the psychologists and the
Freudian types really appreciated and we
understand a little bit from biology is
that there's also a power negotiation in
any kind of interaction like sexual
interaction right because both people
are making themselves very vulnerable if
you look at two dogs when they meet
let's just take animals two dogs when
they meet yeah what do they do they
sniff each other's genitals and the more
submissive one rolls back opens their
legs and is like making their
reproductive potential vulnerable to the
other one biting it off and in the
animal kingdom a lot of animals
hurt other animals not by killing them
yeah they literally trying to rip their
testicles
because when I'm having sex the first
thing I do is roll on my back
so fight off these genitals
so it's interesting because my go-to
will just all the discussions around
consent all right they're very valid
nowadays because what we're really
talking about is that there is
inevitably a power negotiation if I'm on
my back it's always consensual yeah
right think about it if I'm on my back
and always consensual right if I'm on
the bed like this you wouldn't argue the
logic well it might not be content so
there is a phenomenon yeah there is
topping from the bottom topping from the
bottom from the bottom that's that now
you're speaking my [ __ ] laser oh boy
that's me bottom top I'm a bottom side
bro so I'm not a sex therapist nor am I
yeah but but if you look at the speaking
so I look at everything through the lens
of Neuroscience and so we're really
talking about is this brain area called
the hypothalamus which has a mix of
neurons some of them to stimulate mating
behavior some to stimulate violent
Behavior whoa some just stimulate eating
and some to stimulate suppression of
appetite you know some people merge food
and sex in their mind right they think
chocolate and it's and it could be
because they learned you know maybe it
was some you know Valentine's Day
Valentine's Day every day
foreign
[Laughter]
but there was a movie in the I think it
was the 80s or the 90s right I think it
was uh was it like nine and a half weeks
with Mickey Rourke before his face like
was all you know
um and there was a scene I think where
he was like feeding her right and then
it led into sex and that was considered
one of the raciest scenes like the most
provocative scenes just sort of like the
Basic Instinct thing the leg cross
uncross thing like now that's like
that's like nothing
decency standards have have changed
right oh yeah you're saying now you
could get away with that but back now
that's like I'm I'm sure you can find
that as a clip on YouTube right which is
then and you had to like get into the
Raider our movie it was a big deal
people were talking about it and talking
about it I mean I you just remember
these kind of moments in movies and
things have changed I could smell her
through the screen wait you went to 4D
oh that's amazing yeah
yo this clip was brought to you by
rocket money formerly true bill to save
more and spend less join the 3.4 million
members using rocket money at
rocketmoney.com flagrant to get started
for free that's rocketmoney.com flagrant
to get started for free